we all love medicated pete he's one of
our favorite whack packers
pete is super protective of his mom as
protective as pete can be
pete's mom has been single for many
years
we were curious how pete would react to
someone trying to date his mom
it's specifically if it was benji
i mean honestly it all chokes aside i
love benji but i would not want him
dating my mother i just don't i don't
want benji to be my stepfather has a
problem with benji dating his mom
well let what do you think what do you
think you think pete's going to have a
problem with benji or is he going to be
cool with benji you know well i
imagine
in general he has a problem with his mom
dating
well here's benji in his first clip ask
asking pete for permission
if he could date pete's mom
thank you hey how are you doing i'm
gonna feel good
you know i my dayton life i don't know
if you've heard has not been going so
great yeah but uh
i have like a lot of attraction to your
mom oh really you know how like there's
some people you're just like [ __ ]
drawn to
um
and that's how i feel about her i guess
i basically want your blessing to move
forward with it
she's good where she is actually you
know
she's not
she doesn't want to see anybody or date
anybody or do anything like that you
know i don't want her dating other
people i want her you know
i just want to be dating her
uh
that's a tough one
that's a strong one
i i would actually have to have the
thing to think about it you know man
that is selfish of pete
yeah
this got weird benji decides to try
another angle with pete since he you
know pete's kind of saying no you know
right benji it's a tough one
follow this benji then asks pete to role
play as his mom and i thought it was
weird pete was into it
you look like your mom you know yeah
yeah you have your mom's face
no thanks thanks can you um kind of talk
like your mom
hi benji
hey pizza mom how's everything going um
well
seeing you standing here in your towel
walking out of the shower with your
glasses and
yeah it's hot
i gotta kiss your neck
yeah it's pretty hot pretty hard
do you like the way i kiss you
yeah pretty hard pretty hot you feel me
getting hard
looking good
i'm not as big as pete but i'm pretty
thick aren't i yeah
yeah looking good i like that beard
yeah
pretty sexy yeah
yeah it's looking good i love it oh yeah
i love that beard thing
jesus wow what is it
what is going on there benji i think
he likes pretending to be a woman
and uh he likes any kind of contact with
any human being i think
very into it crazy were you freaking out
that he was so into it i mean
wow it
at first it was a little yeah it was a
little it was strange and just funny and
and but then it actually
it
it
it got sexy it actually was like like it
was a weird turn-on kind of feeling so
after all of that the question still
stands did pete agree to let benji date
his mom
and i'm still not sure i'll play you
this clip
your mom's [ __ ] hot oh thanks
when can i ask your mom out when's a
good time to call her i'll put any good
word for it well just put in the good
word
i will and if i date her we can do all
this stuff in person you know i know
that'll be awesome
you got hard yeah you want to let it out
too or i'll probably let it out later
bye pete's mom my benji
hmm that was it wow
yeah those guys had a lot of fun
together
you